[Music]
in cheek full by news for buy like
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a
by news one submitted by Paul from st.
Paul ok said Paul Minnesota what
Minnesota slaughter a Dean resigned over
her school's choice to not allow
chick-fil-a on campus I agree why they
said chick-fil-a happier
I can't be here either is it cuz it
makes the kids too crazy that happened
so quickly
[ __ ] Walter White yeah chick-fil-a
makes kids crazy yes I'm like I'm like a
Asian Blues Traveler there's so much
color on that screen you guys it's all
natural no chick-fil-a probably because
in chick-fil-a you got a new scandal no
they don't like gays yeah how'd you yell
it I mean that's why right and so then
no checkout lanes so it's a gay school
no no way like straight up like yo we
are teaching flame we don't like gays
there you may donate to anti-gay groups
well let's see yeah yeah yeah because
they're super Christian and what does
anti-gay group might be goal out killing
them Norton AntiVirus kills viruses
right what's an anti-gay group they go
out and kill gays
I don't know it's probably for like
legislation and stuff not that fast and
things like that because I know my
husband and I were talking about this
just the other day chick-fil-a is no
weird come out behind us yeah you're
oh I turned 70 for next month chick
please come out and not say not saying
straight out like we don't like gays but
it's like it's more so like we want to
uphold this like the Sancta tude of
marriage between a man and woman right
why don't they just focus on chicken no
like don't like don't talk about it yeah
that's not your industry it's hard to
focus on chicken when you're steaming
about gay people getting but I mean it
is called Church's Chicken oh no its
chick-fil-a Christian some like yeah the
churches what the Phil cage wait no
we're talking about chick-fil-a here and
it's crazy because you have like blue
blockers on and you look [ __ ] unarmed
who you're looking at where are you
looking
you now Stevie wondering that [ __ ]
everyone's over here but he's like he's
like to church's chickens
dude I wish companies will just stay the
[ __ ] out of politics let me just eat
their [ __ ] thing you know doesn't
right in and out like in and out Scott
like they're like John glory 16 like
unlike their the underside of all of
their drinks and stuff but have they
made any noise about like where we stand
have you seen the way they put their
onions though it's always on a cross
stand to have fries that suck ass is
that a big part of it because that would
make sense if you told me that that's
why their fries suck I'd be like oh okay
well those are the five that Jesus ate
though yes Jeff subpoenas cynthaiz
ahjussi I see very very beautiful very
very humble yeah I heard you liked
crinkle-cut fries out of the Bible
Joseph Nazareth silver I want I want
chick-fil-a to be hardcore like
Christian everything in name everything
out of the Bible on their menu
Ezekiel milkshake yes alright Jezebel
fries
ever you share them Jezebel fries yes
the Dean or the former dean of writer
University's College of Business
Administration said that her views as a
very committed Christian and the fast
food chains views mirror one another so
the fact that this university said that
they will no longer be allowing to for
the chick fil-a to be on campus because
of their opposition to LGBT community
she said that it felt like she was
punched in the stomach because that's
like oh [ __ ] oh she loves her
chick-fil-a because she's a very
committed Christian well that's better
for the school she just did everyone on
that campus of huge [ __ ] favor and all
pot to us she really felt like she got
punched in the stomach
yeah one thing her blessing her name is
Cynthia Newman she loves her chick-fil-a
she looks like a chick-fil-a fan that's
exactly who I picture someone with a
double chin like go home from your work
and then go to chick-fil-a like you know
I guess because she said she felt that
because they were pretty much like
banning chick-fil-a because of their
views they're like well how am I she was
like how am I gonna be here with my
views well she did so she's at
university right yeah she didn't know
that [ __ ] like like like people that are
gay or whatever go to universities like
they get an education a higher yeah
that's true but people that are
Christian also go to universities to
should have a right to a Christian skin
Christian school was this a Christian
school it's like a public state school
but it's almost like a state school not
being diverse because they're only being
a bias toward gay and not not inclusive
with Christianity sure so she's not
they're not being like okay well
Christians have their beliefs too and
they're against Chris there against
homosexuality or whatever she's not
letting them coexist and learned that in
this world there are gonna people that
don't agree with you
yeah they're false weird by both the
school and her cuz like the state
schools and university is supposed to be
a place where people from all walks of
life and beliefs can
and meet each other for the first time
and learn about each other accept each
other and accept that there's
differences they don't have to agree but
they that's like the first time where
you get to meet like a devout Muslim guy
or some Chinese kid that's popping
pimples in the bathroom like this that's
the time where you meet all these type
of people and it should be okay yeah I
don't think banging people that I
disagree with is like the coolest yeah
yeah cuz whatever what if there was Taco
Bell and then Taco Bell gave a lot of
money to the NRA or whatever and it's
like I don't know it's just a political
stance right it like how far are they
going with the anti-gay groups like are
they good question yeah cuz if they were
like alright I'm funding a anti-gay
terrorist group that makes sense because
there's violence there's farm there's
all these but if they're just battling
it out through the law to me that's the
that's what we're supposed to do is like
be civil human beings and go into the
government and everyone has our
different like policies you debate and
then you battle it out through that
ground yeah it's like jus true diversity
and true openness means gay is okay but
anti-gay is okay too and they should be
able to coexist together and anti gay
you mean like people who are like over
for who like the man and woman marry I
don't even like the word anti-gay that's
not what I mean more like gays okay and
then traditional guy-girl marriage that
should be okay too and they don't have
to agree but they should be able to
coexist popularly where it gets criminal
is when there's like violence when
there's like you know holding back
people's resources or like one group can
get access but the other can't or like
whatever you know and I don't know I
guess the the the line would be like
marriage right we're like if legally you
couldn't get married because you were
gay because of this group that that
lobbied and said you know only straights
are considered you know married or
whatever then that's where you argue
that but you should have your own gay
group that that's funded and then you
push back and you fight it out through
the law that way - yeah I actually think
a university is a failure if there's one
predominant school of thought
because it should be multiple schools of
thought all coexisting but when they all
agree on one thing that's not what
universities are no because you want it
you don't grow unless you challenge your
thoughts there's even like a lot of like
Christian schools out there with strong
LGBT groups within their group that's
time in schools yeah I think there's
still interesting like lines where it's
like if you're not sleeping with each
other then it's okay but if you're still
with an LGBT group that like that's okay
like it's like it's like a like
behind-closed-doors thing or it's like
don't think with each other but don't
sleep yeah it's kind of nice because
they say that to everybody yeah yeah
that's true they hate sex yeah they
don't like sex at all yeah that's kind
of nice it's kind of equal even straight
people can't have sex yeah don't like
John [ __ ] at all barely ever [ __ ]
must you're making a kid yeah not even
for pleasure you have to have a [ __ ]
blanket with a hole in it and then
there's a big cutout of Jesus oh my gosh
you should be looking into Jesus eyes
while you [ __ ] I just say just so just
so you remember so you never forget
makes you're never forget who's watching
makes awesome yeah if Taco Bell came out
and they said I don't know like were we
want to fund the killing of people with
colored hair for example [ __ ] damn peace
out girlfriend I still [ __ ] love top
so hard I'd be like oh no this is like
that's number one hardest one I'll be
eaten yeah when I use hit it was all
over my timeline like all your gay
friends like I love chick-fil-a like
well I don't know what to do now
yeah cuz there are no gay tongues or
straight tongues are just tongues true
just taste mm-hmm and everybody likes
that chick-fil-a man especially the
sauce the [ __ ] is so good Buffalo's
my [ __ ]
I hate when at the Sunday and I'm
craving the [ __ ] out of chick-fil-a I'm
like I hate that too always a Sunday why
is it always a Sunday
my twice already the same thing I don't
like all that [ __ ] like do you ever been
in a state where you can't get alcohol
on a Sunday
no no it's [ __ ] crazy dude wait there
states that don't serve a whole blue yes
tri-cities Yeah right yeah so then yeah
so on Sunday you cannot buy liquor
because of you know religious Wow those
practices that's crazy I didn't even
know that very frustrating so it's like
what you said about Sunday chick-fil-a
thing it's like dang why is it the only
[ __ ] day I need to drink is Sunday
and that's because it's a football day -
I'm like this should be a [ __ ]
religious day anyway and I think we
should get the day off of work after the
Superbowl because that's a religious day
to me I have a question
is it better for companies to just
completely stay out of it or because
it's like it's like the the justice
Millette stuff really made like a point
of we have to be careful about our
biases you're liking it making sure like
if something goes with our biases that
we don't go so strongly with it just
because it paints a good narrative for
what we believe in yes
and so it's like let's say talk about
funds the thing that you really really
really like I don't like that they're
gonna do that yeah yeah well I mean like
should they should companies just stay
out of it should companies just be the
companies or it like you know like if
companies are like we are advocates for
purple hair I'm gonna be like well shoot
I love taco bell now or like well here's
my thing talkable makes tacos and
burritos and they make them real [ __ ]
well when I hear Taco Bell want to tell
me about something else there's like
John here's talk about stamps on AIDS
I'm like ma'am just tell me about
[ __ ] what you're making right now you
don't mean like a triple then at the
same time there's there's companies like
Target that like like have forward
movement because they've shown like
interracial couples they've shown gay
couples and they take a stance by not
taking a stance and so it's like should
companies stay out of it or its target
out there going like hey there's too
many guns we don't want people to have
guns like you don't say like it's not
that it's not on the nose it's not a
nose you know in the advertisement that
there's two dudes holding hands or
whatever so cool that's that's what
that's cool that the deport that I think
at the end of the day companies just
care about money so they go oh if we
appear like a human being and have these
type of stances on certain things that's
a great way for marketing yeah but some
people like private companies there are
people that use their money for their
passion so it's like like Bill Gates you
know like he's gonna use his money on
his you know foundation yeah cuz he
cares about it and in some cases a smart
marketing right like the Nike thing dude
they generated a lot of clicks and all
that [ __ ] which is what they care about
don't give a [ __ ] about it they want to
make them with sell shoes they want
little tiny children to make shoes for
them yeah and sell them you don't think
so like that's too mean like you said
yeah a date at the other day yeah don't
give us book yeah they just want to stay
relevant and make money
I wonder if chick-fil-a if the if most
chick-fil-a's are in red states and like
we had like a few like here but maybe
we're just not the target demo mmm-hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]